you feel
Resident Evil 7 is Capcom's attempt to
make its beloved horror franchise scary
again by taking the series original
formula of claustrophobic locations and
limited ammo and mixing it with newer
horror concepts like first-person
cat-and-mouse chases this first-person
perspective also allows for a new way to
play virtual reality just an altered
Resident Evil 7 is a big deal for VR
because unlike Batman Arkham VR or
whatever that Final Fantasy 15 thing is
this isn't a short experience re 7 is a
big-budget triple-a numbered sequence so
I saw a golden opportunity by playing
the entirety of Resident Evil 7 in psvr
the whole thing which means experiencing
moments like this and this
and this
[Music]
the game does a good job offering
several adjustable options in VR like
field-of-view
walking speed and Crouch the big thing
is camera rotation options but I'll
admit that none of them are perfect on
the default setting the camera snaps at
angles of 30 45 and 90 degrees this is
the safest option if you want to
minimize the risk of motion sickness but
the jerky nature of it took me out of
the experience the option I used is
called smoothing and while I felt a
little sick at first I was able to get
used to it and play the whole game this
way I would seriously advise caution
though when trying this setting and if
you're prone to motion sickness I would
avoid it all together issues like this
are partly due to the fact that Resident
Evil 7 isn't designed to be VR only it
has to work as a traditional game - this
means no use of PlayStation Move
controllers to simulate your hands the
most you get is the camera is now
controlled by your head so Resident
Evil's virtual reality is less about
enhancing the gameplay experience and
more about immersing you in its
environment the true strength of playing
something in VR is the sense of presence
you gain you are more aware of what's
around you and what's behind you you can
tell how long a hallway is and how close
an enemy is with greater accuracy
you really feel like you are walking
around this mansion and Resident Evil
seven is the perfect game for this
because its environmental design and art
are top-notch the realistic art style
fits perfectly every room is full of
notes to read pictures to look at and
the disgusting imagery my god it's
almost too gross to look at sometimes
this game is gnarly and fantastically
disgusting
regardless of how you play it but being
able to see it so up close without that
disconnect between you and the TV really
makes your stomach churn now let's talk
about everyone's favorite part the
scares there are plenty of those in your
face jump scares that will get you for
sure but for me the memorable moments
come from entering a new location for
the first time and just having to walk
through it you have no idea what's going
to happen next and that is just the
worst feeling I hated and I mean hated
the old house it's dark it's rotting and
I seriously wanted to take the headset
off when the giant bugs showed up we'd
be here all day if I mentioned every
memorable moment but a few standout
scares include crawling inside this wall
full of centipedes walking through neck
eye water and the entirety of this
location after beating the game I went
back in played outside of the AR to see
if there are any differences and the
answer is yes for one it's way easier in
my opinion to shoot in VR because you
can aim with your head this might make
the game slightly easier in VR but I
never found the difficulty balance to be
an issue when playing
this also means if you freak out or try
and look away it messes up your shot
which is pretty neat side note it is
possible to use your added camera
movement from VR to slightly break the
illusion of some scenes it doesn't ruin
anything but it's pretty funny another
thing is that a lot of character
animations are absent in VR stuff like
getting knocked down or jumped by an
enemy doesn't happen this is most likely
because taking camera control away from
you for even a moment would induce
motion sickness having played in VR
first I never missed these animations or
notice their absence but playing it
again I was surprised how many of them
were taken out of course sometimes the
game can't cut scripted moments when
they are story related so to avoid
motion sickness again jarring Lea
switches you to floating in a black void
with a screen playing a pre-rendered
cutscenes in front of you it's the worst
part of the VR experience and that it
quickly reminds you that you are playing
a video game perhaps the strangest part
of playing Resident Evil 7 a second time
without VR is that I think playing in VR
first actually kind of ruined the game
for me it's like when you go back and
we'll get vacation photos it's the same
thing but everything is flat now you
aren't there in the same way there's a
real lack of punch to it don't get me
wrong I still think Resident Evil 7 is a
great game but this is a weird and
slightly amusing issue that I think a
lot of people who play this in VR first
will experience you might also be
wondering what it's like to play a nine
hour game from start to finish in VR
well I wouldn't recommend playing it all
in one day like I did because at the end
of the night my eyes felt really awful
after having a screen stuck to them all
day but other than that I felt fine
you think I'd have wanted to take a
break to save my heart from all the
tension and scares but honestly I was
enjoying the game so much I just kept
wanting to play it
[Music]
my first playthrough of Resident Evil 7
is gonna stick with me as one of those
memorable gaming experiences partly due
to playing it in VR even if it's not a
perfect example of how the technology
can reshape games as we know them
getting to see the Baker Mansion for the
first time that way is something you
only get one chance at and if you have
the opportunity to experience it this
way I highly recommend it it's good by
the way if you are interested in just
watching a bunch of people get scared
playing Resident Evil 7 NVR there is a
video where I threw a bunch of games on
ploy ease into a room for your enjoyment
yeah oh you and if you have played resin
evil 7 in VR or if you want to try it
now let me know in the comments
[Music]